whether or not you enjoy Big Brother
survivor or keeping up with the
kardashians there's no denying that
these long-running reality shows have
figured out a winning formula but a lot
of shows weren't so lucky things can go
wrong on set all the time and when
dealing with regular amateurs instead of
professional actors or experienced
showbiz vets that risk is even greater
from hardcore drug use to gruesome
felonies these reality series all got
cancelled due to some major mistakes
pretty stupid
it isn't easy keeping up with the
kardashians which Alexis Neiers and her
family found out the hard way while
making their reality series pretty wild
which ran for only one season in 2010
the show followed Alexis her sisters and
their mom former playmate andrea
arlington alexis was arrested for
participating in the infamous hollywood
bling ring and jailed for robbing
Orlando Bloom's house all in the first
episode while the legal trouble so early
on should have been something of a red
flag the clincher came later when photos
were leaked of Alexis and her sister
Tess smoking heroin the show was
cancelled for good and both girls
attended rehab armed in foolish you'd
think the only idiot mistake in a show
called armed and famous would be the
premise training celebrities to be
police officers and actually making them
do the job while being filmed for a TV
show
no John is gonna hurt these two girls
not on my watch the stupid doesn't stop
there though the 2007 reality TV dud was
cancelled after just four episodes when
a woman filed a lawsuit against CBS
broadcasting for 1 million dollars
apparently the famous cops had ransacked
her apartment looking for two suspects
before realizing they were at the wrong
address
the network also cited the show's low
ratings as part of the reason for the
cancellation editing error there's
nothing quite like stripping contestants
of all their clothing to raise the
stakes on a reality series this was the
simple concept behind vh1's dating naked
contestants disrobe down to their
birthday suits and went on dates such as
sipping cocktails by the pool or
engaging in some light mud wrestling
romantic right although the participants
needed to bare it all during filming
they were apparently promised that their
naughty bits would be blurred out when
the show air unfortunately whoever was
in charge of the blurring
made a major error during the July 31st
2014 broadcast then 28 year old model
Jesse News wits was wrestling with her
date on the beach when viewers caught a
brief unblurred glimpse of her private
parts Miz which quickly became the
target of ridicule across social media
and filed an ultimately unsuccessful 10
million dollar lawsuit against vh1 owner
Viacom along with two of the show's
production companies eventually the
Parents Television Council who were
staunchly against the show managed to
wrestle 90% of dating make its corporate
advertisers away from the series the
show was canceled shortly after its
third season in 2017 with poor ratings
cited as one of several reasons for the
decision
good grief if you thought the world of
funeral homes was an untapped treasure
trove of reality gold well there might
be a reason for that
in 2014 lifetime was set to produce good
grief a reality series that centered
around the Johnson family mortuary in
Fort Worth Texas but the series wound up
six feet under before it ever got off
the ground on July 15th 2014 the
landlord paid his tenants a visit and
discovered eight rotting bodies hidden
beneath the funeral home when reporters
and paparazzi showed up owner Dondre
johnson initially told the spectators
that's great advertising because in a
few days from now we'll be on a reality
show so I want all this media ultimately
Johnson was found guilty of theft for
stealing money from customers and
neglecting the bodies of their loved
ones in sentenced to two years in prison
and a fine of $10,000 unsurprisingly the
network pulled the plug
[Music]